LAURIE: Welcome to
Photographers at Google.
And it is my supreme pleasure
to introduce Karen Hutton.
She's one of the
most energetic, full
of life people on the planet.
Besides being an
amazing photographer,
here are a few things you
might not know about Karen.
She was an actor-- film,
stage, and television,
voiceover artist who's done
hundreds of commercials,
and she's the voice
of Stuck on Earth,
created by Trey Ratcliff.
Professional ice-skater and
dancer, a horse trainer,
creator of Lil Galleries.
She teaches workshops,
photo workshops,
does virtual photo walks.
And her work has been featured
on the "NBC Nightly News",
and she has a video
chat series called
The Chat with Karen
Hutton, Sound Byte Insights
from Some of the Coolest
People on the Planet.
She also has a list
of firsts on Google+.
She attended the very
first Google+ Photo Walk.
She was one of the first people
to join Google+ a couple years
ago, and she has now over
1.5 million followers.
She was my first Hangout on
Air for Nik Software at Google.
And she was also the
first person I interviewed
for our Google+ Women
in Photography series.
Now today, Karen
is also a first.
She's the first woman for our
Photographers at Google Talk
series.
Her topic today, she'll be
discussing Signature-- Finding
Your Soul's Genius and
Voice in your Photography.
Please give a warm welcome
to the amazing, one and only,
my friend, Karen Hutton.
KAREN HUTTON: Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel exhausted
hearing about my life.
I'm like, I need a rest.
So today, I'm going
to tell you a story.
Because that's what
I do, I tell stories.
And we're going to build
the story together,
and I'm going to
try and remember
that for you, it goes this way.
For me, it goes this way, but
for you, it goes this way.
So I'm going to go this way.
So we're going to
build this story.
How many of you like
to be recognized
for the things you do
and for your photography?
I know I do.
Yes, thank you!
Some of you didn't raise your
hand, and I find you suspect.
But that's OK.
We'll work this out later.
So recognition and being
noticed, some of us
feel ashamed about that.
Oh, I shouldn't
want to be noticed.
Well guess what?
Wanting to be seen, and
heard, and felt, and smelled,
and experienced is one of the
most primal needs of humans,
of human kind.
I mean, we're here to be amongst
each other, be in community.
And not being seen
and recognized
just goes against
everything we know and love.
So when it comes to photography,
I, you know, I've coached.
All these things
that she mentioned,
I've coached them all, too.
And we also didn't
talk about the fact
that I've coached television
news broadcasters for 25 years,
and done photography
all my life.
And so everything I've
ever done, oddly enough,
has been all centered
around, all right,
what does it really mean?
What thing can we
bring to everything
we do that makes
it really special?
That makes it mean something?
That can be kind of
a souls connection?
I don't know what it is
about me that just is always
on this course, but that's the
way it is, so get used to it.
So my opinion-- that's all
we ever really have, is it,
our opinion-- is,
you need a signature.
So what is your signature?
Now obviously, we kind of know
what a signature is, and you're
probably all going to laugh
at me because you're like,
oh, she's such an idiot.
I know what a signature is.
And of course, here's
the definition.
Any unique, distinguishing,
aspect, pattern, feature,
or mark.
But keep thinking, we're
going to apply this
to photography in our story
that we're going to build.
So the thing about signature
that I have learned
is that it bears the
stamp of who you are.
It bears the stamp of
your point of view.
It bears the stamp of your
soul, what you have to say,
what you want, you know,
what I want you to feel,
what I want to feel,
it bears all that.
That's what a
signature is all about.
And inasmuch as all we
have, really, to offer
is us-- is who we are--
that signature really
needs to be in
everything that we're
doing if we want
to be recognized.
Because nobody can do
you as well as you.
Nobody can do you.
Nobody can do me as
well as I can so.
That's why I'm here,
and not someone else.
I would have hired
someone, otherwise.
Kidding!
So we're going to start here.
So signature is
what enables someone
to know that it's you talking.
You recognize your mother's
voice on the phone,
you recognize your dog's
footsteps coming down
the hall way.
There's a lot of
things about someone
you recognize--
the way they dress,
the way they talk, the way they
smell, just the way they are,
their stamp.
They're like, I know you.
Well how do you know you?
It's all those things, right?
And it's the glance,
it's the look,
it's this thing right
here that I'm looking at.
This worldview that
I see here, that I
am going to see here in a
minute, that I see here.
My world view.
My point of view.
I learned this from
an amazing voice coach
that I worked with for a
number of years in Los Angeles.
She works with
celebrities, she works
with-- they call her
the voice whisperer.
Her name is Marice Tobias,
and she uses this term
when teaching us.
Her point of view
about it, which I think
is very true if we
take it from voice
and put it into
photography, it is
what it is like to be in
the presence of your voice.
So when we talk
about a voice, when
she's talking to us
about voice, we're
talking about speaking voice.
But I'm talking to you about
the voice in your photography.
Your voice.
So what is it like to be in
the presence of your voice?
Now, this signature idea
is also what enables you
to, as the feed comes through
your Google+ stream, you know,
here comes a Trey Ratcliff,
here comes a Thomas Hawk,
here comes whoever
you follow and admire.
Oh, I know that work.
Guess how you know that work?
Because the signature's in it.
It's all over it.
You see it.
You know it.
That's what we want
in our photography.
Would you agree
that's a good thing?
Yeah.
Good.
Glad we're on the same page,
because we have a whole story
here to create.
So when you talk about
this idea of, what
is it like to be in the
presence of your voice,
most great artists
I know of, they're
always in this state of
like, humble amazement.
Because they know-- the really
good ones know-- that it's not
them that's putting the
art-- the photograph
or the art on the canvas
or making the sculpture--
they know it is this
spark of divine fire
that is coming through them.
And that their job is
to stay clear enough
to allow this thing to happen,
so that when they're done,
they look at that,
and they're amazed.
They're like, damn!
That came through me?
Right?
That's art.
So right here, at the
beginning of our story,
were taking
photography and we're
going to talk about it as art.
Because yes, there's
journalistic, yes,
there's snapshot at a party.
But even that can
have a signature.
And because of what I
want to talk to you about,
because the amazing thing I've
noticed over the years is that
people who engage in this
whole signature process end up
in a different place in
their life people who don't.
And I have found
that fascinating.
And it doesn't matter if it's
in photography, in voice,
in acting, in all these things
that I've done, it all the.
Same it's amazing.
So a signature cannot be bought.
It cannot be borrowed.
O course, when I
first heard about it,
Marice was telling us
all about signature
and I got so nervous,
because I was like,
oh my God, now I
need a signature.
Where do I get it?
Do I buy one?
Is there a sale?
Is there something online?
Can I, uh-- but no.
It's actually kind
of this inner process
that you have to go
through to bring it out.
And in photography, if we break
it down to make it simple,
because what I'm saying is
all very good in theory,
but what does it really mean?
There are elements
to a signature.
There are things you
already know about yourself
that, if you focus on
them in your photography,
it already creates an
interesting, different, unique
point of view.
So I'm going to show
some photos of my own.
Not because like, I'm
the best photographer
on the face of the earth.
I'm OK.
But I have a signature,
I've thought a lot about it.
And I chose some photos that
show it in a really simple way
so that we can have a
discussion about it.
So this is one.
Now, I mentioned before,
I am always on a journey.
I didn't use that word,
but I'm a journey person.
I'm always going
from here to there.
I can't stand still.
I don't think that's our
nature to stand still.
I think evolution is
just part of who we are.
So one of the elements
that tends to show itself
over and over are,
we're going somewhere.
So I love leading lines.
So we have leading lines.
We';re going on a journey.
We have the mystical mist.
I love the mystical mist.
I require a certain amount
of mystical mist in my life.
In this case, we
had a mystical mist,
because there was some fog.
But there wasn't enough,
so I added a little bit.
And I don't mind doing
that, because this
is my expression of my reality
and I'm going to put it out
there and that's what
I'm going to roll with.
I love the light from above.
I love the pop of color.
I love that it's
warm and then cool.
And I love that it just
makes you want to go and see
what's around the
corner, because I
think that is the
nature of life.
And that is how I live
my life and that's
how I think about it.
So, boom.
I would say of many of
the photos that I have,
this has probably been one
of the more shared photos,
probably, on the internet.
So it must strike a
chord with people.
I know it's got
more of the elements
with-- between light, and magic,
and mystery, and leading lines,
and the journey,
and the colors, I
would say it has
probably the most
elements of my own signature
in it of most photos that I do.
I don't really know why
it got shared so much,
but anyway, it did.
So there you go.
And it's in the +1
collection book.
I believe it's on Page 10.
I'm not sure.
I could be wrong about that.
I knew it at one point.
Anyway, so then, perspective.
And leading lines.
If you know your
signature and you know
you're the kind of person that
looks at things differently,
than that's going to inform
where you hold your camera.
You can hold it here.
You know, if the
normal shot is like,
I'm going to shoot
all of you, but now I
want to get a
different perspective,
maybe I'll hold it up.
Maybe I'll hold it down.
Maybe I'll hold it sideways.
How you see the world
will inform you.
So this is in Florence.
And it was a lovely
shot, holding
the camera-- did
I have a tripod?
I don't think I had a tripod.
Had I had a tripod, it
would have been a nice shot
just here.
But I put the
camera on the ground
and tipped it up and put it a
little bit crooked because I
thought, if I were a little
critter crossing the road
and I looked up and look down,
is it safe, shall I keep going?
That's what it would look like.
And then because it's
a little critter,
I might as well go with the
movie moment, which I'm always
playing movies in my
mind, and process it
in kind of a movie kind of
animated sort of fun way.
So that's how I
decided to take that
and that's how I decided to
process it was, my perspective.
So just examples.
Light.
I'm all about light.
Life is light.
My photography business
tag is, Karen Hutton, Life
is Light Photography.
Because I think we chase
light as photographers.
We wait for light, we curse
the light, we judge the light,
we wait, we live for the
light, we get up for the light,
we stay up for the light,
and I think life is light.
So light features in
a lot of my photos.
I love to shoot
into the sun, which
is one of the reasons why I do
a lot of HDR, which this is,
because it's just easier to
get all the levels of light
when you're shooting into
the sun like an idiot.
Leading lines, the
nugget in the front,
you kind of stop and see
things along the way,
but you're on a journey,
the reflections, all
that is just part of who I am.
Journey-- now it's
not going that way.
Now we have a bike getting
ready to go out and take
the journey that way.
So journey.
And again, kind of a surreal
processing purposely.
Jouney, hi.
How are you doing?
Two-tone.
This just feels like a slice.
You know how when
you have a dream,
and all you remember
is this-- I remember--
and then you have
this one frame.
And you're like, what
did that attach to?
What was going on?
I just remember this
one frame from my dream.
Do you ever have that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KAREN HUTTON: Yeah.
That's was what this
was like for me.
Journey.
We're going somewhere .
We're going somewhere.
And in between is
this dream state,
which is why I used the sort of
surreal blue two-tone approach.
I'll show you the before later.
I decided the boardwalk didn't
have enough curve in it,
so I gave a little
more curve, as well.
Because I personally, this
is a thing in my life.
My husband's here,
and he'll tell you.
If reality doesn't suit me,
I will fix it to suit me.
Because I like, yeah,
that doesn't work for me.
Could you-- yeah.
I do that.
So that's going to show up
in my photography, as well.
Lines.
Here we have a nice combo.
We have a little
journey going on here.
leading line action.
We have the enormity and
beauty of these big trees.
I threw this in here,
too, because people often
wonder how to shoot forests,
because sometimes they
can look really
messy and chaotic.
And if you can find
some really strong lines
and make that the story--
because this is a story--
then it helps a photo a lot.
This was interesting.
Brian and Nichole
will recognize this.
In the Columbia Gorge, Columbia
River Gorge, Horsetail Falls,
right?
I think.
Was there with Brian Bonham.
Anyway, these
trees are like, oh,
they're so amazing
when you're in them,
but how do you shoot them?
So I decided that the
character of these trees
was, they had these arms.
These like, woo,
and you'd better not
get caught by one of those arms.
Or, it could be
prehensile fingers.
Either way, they're alive
and they have intelligence.
And so I decided that
this would be their body,
and those would be their
arms, and the waterfall behind
gives them a little
break in the green
and makes it all stand out.
And to me, that
made a character.
Like, that could
be on a story board
in my movie of a character
that looks like that.
So welcome to my mind.
It's A scary place.
So just, again, light
features in the leading lines.
Another thing that's really
helpful, if you think about it,
is, these trees were huge.
They were probably-- well, I'm
terrible at distance, but well
over 200 feet tall.
They're very, very big trees.
And I decided that the better
shot was not to show it,
because then I'm explaining
the whole thing to you-- Oh,
they're this big, which
never really shows up anyway.
You can never show that kind
of perspective in a photo.
So imply it.
Create some nice leading
lines, a nice little sunburst.
I love sunbursts.
And imply the height and let
the viewer fill in the rest.
It's a lot more fun for them,
and it's entertaining for you,
and the kids will love it.
Perspective.
So I'm all about perspective.
I am opinionated, I will admit.
But I try not to
be too judgmental,
and I'm really, really
about perspective.
Because if you have the right
perspective about things,
you don't have to be in
an adversarial position
in your life.
You can actually understand
things and go, "Ah."
Because as an actor,
that's what we had to do.
If you got a character in a
show, you couldn't just say,
I hate her.
She's stupid.
How do you play that?
You can't .
You can't be in judgment of
what you're participating in.
So perspective is really
important in life, I think,
and in photographs.
So here in Siena, my
first trip to Siena,
which was hugely
impactful for me because I
had read about it as a kid.
There a book called,
"Gaudenzia, Pride of the Palio."
Ooh, about a horse
and the Palio race.
And I never forgot that book.
It was, God, I probably read
that-- OK, a lot of years ago.
We won't go into that.
So this was the
history in this place.
And the mystery in this place
at night just blew me away.
But it wasn't-- if I
held the camera straight,
everything was straight.
And I used a 14
millimeter on this.
But if I held it
straight, it was
like, it was too post card-y.
It was too travel brochure.
So I said, and besides
which, these buildings all
felt like-- felt to me--
like they were looking down
at us, going, pfft--
another batch.
They're just like the
ones 400 years ago.
And I'm like, whoa, they're
like, they're so old.
So anyway, I took it and
turned it, and deliberately
pulled this corner of
this building down,
because that's what
those big lenses do,
is they distort-- I
love that distortion--
and offset the center so that
they would feel like people.
So they would feel like beings.
Maybe not people, but their
own being kind of looming down.
And left that light
in there because life
is light, so might as well.
And that became my
impression of that place.
So again, my
signature in for me.
So I'm just going to roll
through a few more of these.
Same thing, looking up.
I have a tendency to look up.
Kind of a looker upper.
Kind of like to see
the glass half full.
Don't make a face, Brian.
And this is one,
this is comparing,
this is like a
contrast in the old
and the new, two kinds
of wood, you know?
The growing up and
the disintegrating.
The contrast, the
juxtapositions.
I love all those
things, so I tend
to look for those
in my photographs.
Same thing here.
Everybody and their
brother-- we all--
has anybody shot this
car down in Bodie?
Nobody's copping to it.
It's an amazing car.
You should go shoot it.
And everybody shoots
it who goes to Bodie.
And I almost didn't,
because I'm like, hell,
everybody shoots that car.
Then I thought, well
what's that car's story?
So I decided that the
car's story was-- well,
and it didn't occur to me
until I brought my camera down,
and all of a sudden,
it had a face.
So all of a sudden, it became
this like, poignant story
of this family car that
was once loved and beloved,
now sitting out here in this
field with the grass growing up
and time is like,
reabsorbing it.
And as I got down
there, mind you,
I'm someone who hears
music and like full scores
of movies and dialogue
and the whole thing,
it's kind of frightening.
Laurie has occasionally
said, "I just want
five minutes in your mind."
She said one day, I think she's
got it down to like, a minute.
30 seconds.
I don't want to be
in there too long.
Anyway, so down,
it became the story
this car that is like,
waiting. it's outside, right
and its owners are getting
ready to go to town,
and the car's like, oh,
we're going on a ride!
And then she hears the
owners in the house
going, "Fire up Bessie,
we're going to town!"
And she's Bessie, so, OK.
You're probably
learning more about me
than probably should be sharing.
But anyway, I make movies
in my mind everywhere.
So again, a frame
out of my movie.
You're welcome.
This was the photo that
was on NBC Nightly News.
It was the final shot of
a virtual photo walks,
a story on virtual photo walks.
Because I had done
a virtual photo
walk from Hovenweep, which
is where this was taken.
And time, this is like
the time machine shot.
This is like the
old and the new,
the sun and the light being
of the moment, right now,
and this 1,200-year-old
ruins is, so not right now,
and yet it is.
And the sun, the light,
is what connects them.
So it was kind of a, again,
strange link, as I see life.
So I have lots of photos here.
You probably don't
need to see them all,
but I'm just going to kind
of thumb through them.
You can sort of see-- "Harold
and Maude" was a movie.
Did anybody of you ever see
that movie? "Harold and Maude"?
So somebody had carved Harold
and Maude on the side of this.
And the sun was there, and
it was like, oh my God.
I have to take this picture.
Because this is a movie
moment, a light moment,
kind of a crazy moment.
Harold and Maude
and their story.
Textures.
I love texture, I love
dreams, and altered realities.
I'll show you befores and
afters of some of these.
These are mostly
for the textures.
Perspective, again,
small and large.
And then we have small and
large with the large implied.
That's in New Zealand.
Sunsets.
I love my sunsets.
I didn't put the 2,000 sunset
photos that I've got in here.
Just a few that
just tell a story.
And again, I love color.
I grew up with black and white.
That was my professional
training, went to school
and we studied black and white.
But somehow, I've
evolved into this--
I don't know-- time or
this age, or who I am now,
and I just love color.
I'm just like, oh, I love color.
So I tend to, you
know, although I
didn't have to do
too much to this.
This was pretty much
crazy that night.
That was pretty much
I love my animals, because
I grew up in the country.
And I love the connection that
animals have with the world
around them.
So those are just some things.
So I'm just trying
to show elements
through my photos
of what I'm talking
about when we talk
about signature.
So when we're talking
this way, we're
talking about
photography as art.
So I have-- I never
remember this,
I always have to read
it-- the definition of art
is the expression or application
of human creative skill
and imagination, producing works
to be appreciated primarily
for their beauty
or emotional power.
So art values beauty
and emotional power.
Now, I think we all know
what's beautiful to us.
I think it's undervalued
in our society,
and I think there was a point in
history where that decision was
made to split off
between science and art.
That's a history lesson, we
won't go into that today.
That's tomorrow.
Kidding!
Don't come back here
tomorrow looking for that.
So the thing about
art, though, art--
I'm gonna actually put this on
the screen-- art lets us dream.
So art is a place we go when
we want something better.
Like I mentioned before,
our spark of divine fire.
The place where we go
for something better,
for our higher view, for ah,
more, what more could there be?
We go to art.
And by art, it
could be your life,
it could be your photography,
it could be something you do.
But artful living, that is a
living your life as an art,
right?
And that's kind of
what I'm talking about.
And the thing of it
is, this is not new.
I was curious to see--
oh, this does look good.
So Rumi-- how many of you know
Rumi, the mystic and poet,
right, from the 1,200s,
the 13th century.
He said, "Let yourself
be silently drawn
by the strange pull of
what you really love.
It will not lead you astray."
I think that's really important.
That was how many years ago?
And he was telling people this.
Why?
Because I think people
make choices about,
well, I'm going
to feel this way,
or I'm going to do this,
because it will get me that.
Something on the outside.
When in fact, the thing
that gets you recognized,
the thing that leads
you to something better,
or to a better
photograph, is what
you love about the photograph,
about your perspective,
about your processing,
about how you're
going to make your voice, which
is what signature is leading us
to-- how you're going to
make that heard, and seen,
and smelled, and felt, and
every other sense that you
can possibly pack in.
The late 1800s, James
Allen, who was a writer,
he wrote about-- he wrote
kind of, not a spiritual list,
but he wrote about--
I guess you'd call him
a self-help author of the 1800s.
"The vision that you
glorify in your mind.
the ideal that you enthrone
in your heart, this
you will build your life by."
No matter what.
Even if you don't choose to.
Whatever you think about
and feel about the most,
that is what you will
build your life by.
That is what you will become.
So if art, carried all the
way back to your photographs,
allows you to dream, to
dream of something better,
to dream of wow, I didn't
think of doing it like this.
What if I do?
That process starts to find
its way into your life.
And this is one of the
real big powers, to me,
of photography and art.
More recently,
Gloria Steinem said,
"Without leaps of
imagination or dreaming,
we lose the excitement
of possibilities."
And that's what we're
really talking about here,
is having possibilities.
"Dreaming, after all,
is a form of planning."
Which I love.
I love that.
So what would you attempt to do
if you knew you could not fail?
Whether it's photography,
whether it's life.
What dream would you have
about this photograph,
about this vision, about
what you want to do,
and who you want to become,
if you knew you couldn't fail?
So yeah, you thought
we were going
to talk about
photography, didn't you?
Ha!
So this brings us to story.
We use our photographs
to tell a story.
We dream of a story.
Like, I mean, I just
took you through some
of my crazy photographs, right?
Oh, I think I'll
do this with it.
Because it's a story.
How many of you heard Alan
Shapiro's talk last month
about words?
Yeah.
If you haven't seen it, you
should go back and watch it.
It's fantastic, where he talks
about words and the importance
of words with your photographs.
I think there are, in fact,
three kinds of stories.
I think words are huge,
and I think beyond that,
we have stories.
And I think there
are three kinds.
And I think we have stories
that give, stories that take,
and stories just for
the facts, ma'am.
Examples of stories that give--
stories that give are like,
throughout history we have
our ancestors and families
and civilizations who have
passed on, either through
pictographs or whether it's
written or through song
or whatever, whatever they
did, they told us how to --
what they encountered, what
to watch out for, how to have
families, how to have fun,
how to laugh, what to eat,
what not to eat.
All those things, those
are stories that give.
They help us live.
Other stories that give
from more modern times
are stories of inspiration.
Stories that like, wow,
I had this thing happen.
I lost my leg, but this
is how I overcame it.
Or had this bad thing happen,
but this is what I did.
This is how I made it work.
Stories that lift you up.
Stories that inspire.
Stories that empower.
Those are stories that give.
Same with photographs.
Stories that take--
good example-- this
is a really good example.
You can all relate to this one.
Is, you have a voice in
your head that says, God,
you're stupid.
Oh, my God, why
did you say that?
You are so fat.
Why aren't you exercising?
You are so lazy.
Oh my God, that was a
stupid thing to say.
Have any of you ever
heard any of these?
You're all kind of going,
no, yes, yes, no, yes.
We all have.
That's our critical
voice inside,
and it tells you a
story about yourself.
It tells you a story about
yourself that in many cases,
people assume is right--
or maybe they don't even
question it.
They just start living it.
Oh my God, that's true, OK.
So pretty soon, that
becomes the filter--
the lens-- through which
you live your life,
process your photos,
take a photograph.
I'm never successful
because-- I could never
win because-- I just
wanted it to be this way,
but it can't because, whatever,
oh my God, I'm tired now.
So stories that take.
On the outside,
pretty much any story
that you hear from someone else
that makes you feel like crap?
That's a story that takes.
It's taking away.
It disempowers.
It makes you less than.
It makes you doubt.
It makes you feel lousy.
Those are stories that take.
I had a very incredible mentor
in my life who was my voice
coach, and I did personal
development with her
for many, many years.
So I think it might
have been-- it
might have been 30 years
ago-- she said to me,
we were talking about
the inner voice, right,
the one that was stories.
She said to me, she said,
if it tells you a story
and it makes you
feel bad, it's a lie.
Pure and simple.
No ifs, ands, or buts.
If it makes you feel
bad, it is a lie.
And 30 years ago, I
said, that's a lie.
I just can't believe it's that
simple because blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
Because I had so many stories.
Well, I've field tested
this sucker for a long time,
and I'm now on the page
where I realize she's right.
If it makes you feel
bad, it is a lie
and is a story that takes--
and give it the boot.
Whatever you've got to do.
So art allows us to
find those, allows
us to discover
those for yourself.
Because if you're in your
artistic state, and let's
say you're processing-- how
many of you process photos?
Yeah, OK, so we're
on the page here.
I wondered about that.
So you're processing
the photo and you
let yourself go in this
zone where, OK, this
would be beautiful, or this.
I feel like trying this.
Or let's try this.
And it starts to feel
amazing, and all of a sudden,
you find yourself, like
it's been a hard day,
but now you're having some fun.
And oh, my God, you're
in your happy place,
and wow, I never
thought of doing that.
And you're in this
sort of uplifted place,
you start to realize,
wow, the rest of the time,
I feel really crappy.
Why is that?
You almost need the
contrast to even find out
how much you're
beating yourself up
or how much you believe
bad stories, or whatever,
to know that there's another
choice that you could make.
Stories just for the
facts have their place.
They're not
particularly emotional.
The first two are very
emotionally loaded.
The third one is like, what's
the story of this photograph?
What did you do?
Well, I used my Canon 5D Mark
III, I used my 24-70 2.8.
These settings, I shot
it HDR, and then I
processed it and
used the software.
And that was how I did this
photo-- which is valuable.
Some people need that.
The DMV needs to know what
happened in the intersection
when your car got crunched.
Those are important stories,
but they're not emotional.
They're not going to inform
you the way these other two do.
And since we're talking art--
so we started with signature,
right, and we talked about art
and it allows you to dream,
so now we're in this
part of the story.
And now we're coming
over here, we're
coming into another place of
the story, which is, what if?
What if is one of
my favorite-- I
always call it a game
because I like to have fun--
but it's one of the most
powerful games, tools,
out there.
What if allows you to
play a different game.
What if allows you to say, well,
this is how it seems to be.
But what if it were like this?
What if I tried that?
It starts to lift the lid off
of-- it's always like this
and I'm always in pain, right?
And it allows you to start to
crack open some perspective.
Where's that microphone?
I'm going to show
you a video, but I
have to do it a certain way.
It's here?
Oh.
Is it on?
So I'm going to play you
a story about possibility,
about perspective.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Constructs-- complex
ideas, images,
or theories formed from a
number of simpler elements.
In our minds, we
built constructs
to give ourselves order,
structure, safety.
And sometimes, they do.
Sometimes, they lead us down
roads we never intended to go.
Patterns repeat.
Sameness mounts.
Until it seems our
world of construct
spins out of control, until
our heart speaks of freedom.
Our soul reflecting
passion we never imagined.
Our world becomes enormous.
And suddenly, we
seem quite small.
Even insignificant.
But we are not.
We are all part of
something greater.
Something fluid, and deep.
And a connection to an
incredible strength.
Beauty lives here.
And a visionary inside that sees
things differently, uniquely.
Greeting that one is like
a new dawn-- soaring.
Inside every construct lies
the chance to see a new light.
A chance to travel new roads.
The chance to marvel at
the world around you.
And when that happens,
the light prevails.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KAREN HUTTON: What if?
What if you take the
things in your signature
and create something new?
That was what I was trying to
do with these Lil Galleries.
Is online now, at
Lil Galleries.com,
but it's these
combinations of voice.
Photographs contain your voice.
In my case, I just
happened to have a voice
that I use as a voice.
And I wondered what would
happen if I put them
together and created a
third way of speaking
through these videos.
So what if?
What if you did that?
What if you took-- I
don't know, a photograph.
What if you took
this photograph?
This is a cool photograph of a
house, of a broken down house.
It's got a story.
It's out in the middle of
this big old, humongous,
I don't know how many-- I
guess you measure it in miles.
It's just a huge, huge valley.
It has some cattle.
And you look at that
and you go, wow.
That is really something.
That house has a story to tell.
Nice telephone lines, by the
way, it's really awesome.
And it's got some cool colors.
Now, I see it in
black and white,
because that's my
background, and this
looks very black and white.
But I had to play with color.
And I said, what if this is in
a transit place, this house?
What if we made it in a
transit place in its own world?
And what if the light
were shining on it
and giving it its due
and telling its story?
And what if it were
black and white?
It's off the screen.
That becomes another story--
another way to tell the story.
And black and white is so
interesting, because there's so
many shades of black,
and white, and gray,
and what if we did that?
And what if we made that
feel like it's another era?
That looks like photos that
my grandmother used to have,
that I still have, that
I inherited from her.
Now suddenly, I
feel like I'm there.
And then what if we
made it even more stark?
What if we made it so
dramatic and so contrasted
that it tells a whole
different story?
That's just me playing
my what if game one day.
But that what if, and
then taking the action.
So now we're signature,
we're art and dreaming,
now we're what if'ing, and
now we're putting into action.
Because inspiration is great.
Dreams are important.
All those things, you've
got to get to those.
But if you don't put it into
action, if you don't actually
put it into something, this
whole creative universe
that we live in is meant
to be manifested in.
It's meant to create things.
If you don't create things,
if you don't follow through,
it kind of just falls flat.
So here, by going-- I'm going
to show you some befores
and afters, only because
we're playing what if, right?
We're going to play
this what if game.
Shot of Siena, it's nice.
It's fine.
It's a good Facebook shot.
Whatever.
So but what if I made
it feel like something
I would find in a curio shop,
or after I dug through an art
store that had some stuff
thrown at the bottom of a box?
What would that look like?
I love textures.
Of course I love my colors.
This was New Zealand.
It had the bones.
It had the right bones.
It had the mountain and the
trees, and the sky just sucked.
It just did.
It should have been prettier,
but I couldn't come back,
and I was here,
and I'm like, well,
what if I made it look
the way I want it to look?
That's my life right there!
That's what I want!
Right?
So, I mean, again, my husband
can attest to the fact
that I do this to
pretty much everything.
So I'm like, that's how
it should look, by golly.
And then this!
Oh, my God, how often--
well, maybe some of you
get to Paris more than I did.
I got there once.
And it was snowing.
It was December.
It was a crappy day.
I got all this schmoo
all over my lens.
And I'm looking
at this, I wanted
to take a really cool-- I call
it Notre Dame-- Notre Dame
shot.
And wow, that's what I got.
That's the raw.
Isn't that pretty?
And I was like, damn it!
Like, where's sky?
Where's the drama?
Where's the-- But I took it a
little skew-y because again,
I had that looming thing.
So to me, she's
the school mistress
and these are her minions.
And they run around
and harass the students
and the minions are
like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
So that was-- those
are the bones.
I got the bones.
It just wasn't all
there, so I put it there.
Because that's what I saw.
That sky-- of course, I've had
this conversation with Brian
in the past.
There was a time when
I didn't do skies,
and he scoffed at
that years ago.
And I do skies now.
Because without it,
I wouldn't have that.
And gosh darn it, I only
go through this life once.
I'm going to have
my, that, by golly.
Because you're not going
to give it to me, right?
Oh, here, I'll give you that.
Yeah, right.
OK.
I'll make my own.
Thank you, very much.
So this attitude, you cannot
help but have it travel
into the rest of your life.
You are not a
compartmentalized being.
You're just not.
So you do stuff like
this in your photography
and you start playing, and
playing what if, and actually
creating something and
putting it out there
and getting feedback,
and oh, my God!
Pretty soon, you go,
well that was really fun,
where else can I do that?
Right?
And that's when your
life starts to change.
It's a transformational process.
So here's that shot I
was telling you about.
I didn't like the boardwalk,
it was too straight.
So I bent it and did that to it.
And this was, God, it should
have been such a good shot.
And now it is.
Same thing here.
I felt like this is
kind of very ent-like.
You know, the ents.
Of like, it's going to
crawl into the water,
and it had its little boulders
already leading the way.
So I'm like, it's there, and
yet, it's not really there,
is it?
Oh, yes it is.
Now it is.
And it's got some dream.
You know my mystical mist?
My magic, my dream?
I got to have that.
Nice shot, it's OK.
Whatever.
Oh, I like it better now.
Yeah, a little texture,
a little extra color.
It was all there.
I didn't have to add a lot.
It isn't like I sat there
and made something up.
There's plenty of nights
I've shot on this pond, which
is near my home, that those
colors were in the sky.
It just didn't happen to me
that night, so I put it there.
Meh!
So sue me!
This was OK.
See, I know-- I could see it in
certain lights-- this water was
so incredibly green-blue.
But in this shot,
it didn't show.
And I was like, oh, yes it does.
Yeah!
That's what I saw.
So this is what I do.
I go around playing, what if I
do this, and what if I do that.
This, you know, I went and did
the Trey Ratcliff's New Zealand
Adventure.
I was one of the coaches
for his first one,
and this was one of
the places we went.
And it was an unfortunate sky.
It just was really
boring until I did that.
Because not it's got some drama.
Like it or not like it.
You don't have to like it.
I really don't care.
My point is, in
showing you this,
is, this is how I felt it.
I mean, this is the drama, this
is the color, this is the yum,
this is what I loved
about this moment,
because this is how I felt.
The same thing here.
What was funny about
this this, though,
was I was shooting
this in Hawaii,
this gorgeous, you know,
the sky and everything.
And I did shoot it HDR,
this is one exposure.
But there was a photographer
out there shooting
his bride-- he was doing a bride
shoot-- an engagement shoot.
And they were out
on this rock, and I
was like, you're ruining my
shot-- which is hilarious,
right?
But I said, oh well, I'm
going to clone stamp you.
So I did.
Oops.
I went too far.
Sorry, hitting this
thing too hard.
So I clone stamped them.
Gave them a little
Hawaii 5-0 twist,
and we have that, which I like.
And then this was one--
we were going somewhere,
and of course, Trey gets in
his car and, "We're going!
We're not stopping!"
Well, we do stop sometimes, but
at this point, we were going,
I'm like, "Wait!"
So I took that as
we went racing by,
because I was like-- it's
the bones, it's the bones.
I see bones.
I see that.
Because I saw it like
an old canvas painting,
you know, like stored in Italy.
So this is the point where
you get to take your world
and make it something different.
And this is what we did here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - 01 040823,
"CALEB DOLISTER"]
-Alone.
Voices from the past.
Screaming.
Echoing.
Alone.
Is anyone there?
Anyone?
Get me out.
It's time.
Find the key.
Come back to me.
Live my dreams.
Love is the key.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KAREN HUTTON: So we did that.
Because I figure,
I have a voice.
I have two voices.
I'm very fortunate.
I have photography
and I have my voice.
And I'm going to use it.
I'm going to use them both.
I m going to use them
any way I can come up
with when I say, what if.
What if I tried this?
Will galleries?
I don't know.
I didn't really have a super,
like huge vision for it.
It was just, what if I
take other people's work
and we make a story
about something amazing?
What if we take grunge,
like the pain of death,
practically, and
reinvigorate with life?
What does that look like?
What if we did that?
So that's what that
story was about.
So here's the thing.
Is it by living
your life artfully,
by chasing after your
photography an artful way--
think about when you
hold your camera, what's
going to tell the story?
Is it told better from here?
Is it told better like this?
Is this a straight
documentation,
or do I want to skew it?
Think about, well how do I feel?
What do I stand for?
This is the part in
the story, right,
we started with legacy,
now it's our dream,
and how it's what if.
Now we're creating something and
we're moving it into the world.
Now all of a sudden, it's
a motor, it's a machine,
it's moving through the world.
And it is leaving your
mark wherever you go.
If you feel invisible,
you are not invisible.
And you'll be less
invisible, feeling invisible,
if you are thinking
about what you
have to say, what your
stand is going to be,
what mark you're going to
leave, what people are going
to say about you and think
about when you're gone.
Not just from the room,
but from this life.
Is it going to be different?
Or is it just going to be
the same old, same old?
I get caught in the same
thing everybody else does.
I work off a list,
which is stupid.
But at the same time, I go,
all right, I've got a list.
But what does it mean?
What are the things
that I want to do
that are going to
make a difference?
What are the things
I want to say?
Who do I want to be?
I can bitch and moan
and whine and complain
better than probably
any of you in here.
Because I got some drama.
I got some juice behind it.
But why?
What's the point?
And when it comes photography,
I can shoot realistic.
That's my background.
I can see black and white.
I can be all art and I can
be all traditional, but why?
I know, I have something to
say, and I'm going to say it,
dammit.
So quit arguing with me.
So this is-- I have been
doing a show called, "The Chat
with Karen Hutton", Sound
byte-sized insights from some
of the coolest
people on the planet.
Nichole Young has been on there.
Lauren Rubin has been on there.
And the reason I'm doing it
is because I look around.
I look around at
photographers and their issues
and what they're
trying to accomplish.
And they want to be more,
they want to be bigger.
They want to be this,
they want to be that.
We've got to cross train.
I've been fortunate to do so
many things-- so many things--
that I've discovered the thread
that pulls them all together.
And it's the stuff we're
talking about right now.
So on "The Chat", my
goal is to develop,
for however long
I do this show, is
to develop a library
of people who
are living their life
artfully, thoughtfully,
in a way that perhaps
isn't traditional.
But who are finding a way
to take that part of them
that they're passionate about--
these could be photographers,
they could be musicians,
singers, businesspeople,
they can be anyone who is
living their life a little bit
differently.
We're going to have a short
chat, it's a 15-minute show.
And share, OK, so what
have you discovered?
What did you find out?
You know how when
you get together?
What did you find
out along the way?
I want to steal from that.
That's the intent behind there.
And that's why.
Because these are
people who have taken
those dreams and have put
them out into the world.
How did they do that?
We want to know.
So in moving toward
wrapping this thing up,
our story signature, we dream,
we what if, we actually do it.
Now we're doing it.
This is when it
informs your life.
Because it's never enough just
to process a photo this way.
You feel so fricking
good, you want
to do it in your whole life.
So this then becomes,
what is your legacy?
You're all very young.
Most of you here
are younger than me.
I'm older than you think.
And I'm at a point
now in my life
where-- in the
beginning of my life,
I said, oh my God, there's
so many things I want to do,
I've got to do them all.
That's why Laurie read
such a long list of things.
Because when I was
really young, I said,
I'm going to do
all these things.
Now have to do these
when I'm young,
because when I get
to be this age,
I'm not going to have
good knees, so I'm
going to be able-- you
know, so I kind of like,
have worked my way
through my list.
Now I'm at a point
where I'm like, OK,
what difference did it all make?
What can I do to help people
who are behind me coming through
to get here faster?
Why do they have to
suffer the way I did?
I had some amazing mentors--
some amazing people
in my life who
showed me the way.
In elders who lived
by vision and who
created their life
in a certain way
and informed my art and my life.
That's kind of who I want to be.
If I'm talking about light,
and journey, and lines,
and so on and so forth, what
is my legacy going to be?
And it shows up in my art work.
It absolutely shows
up in my photography.
I'll pass up shots because
I'm like, that's a nice shot,
but what's the point?
What's the story?
I'm always walking around.
If I see something that
attracts me, and I go,
OK, OK, this is cool.
This is cool, but
what's the story?
What's the story?
And that tells me
where to put my camera.
And then I most often see it
processed, but sometimes not.
Sometimes I just know the vibe,
and I know if I shoot it right
and compose it right,
it's going to talk to me.
You all know now,
that actually happens.
It's going to talk to me
when I go to process it.
So you and your
photography-- I challenge you
to this-- what
will be your story?
What are you going to tell?
What words are you going to use?
How is it going to
inform your life?
How are you going to
start seeing the world?
This is the gift that we have.
Artists have to take weeks, and
months, and years, sometimes
to create their work.
All we got to do is
hold up a camera.
What's the story?
What difference you're
going to make to the people
who come along behind you?
And how are you going
to tell that story
through your
photographs, which will
evolve as you go through life?
It'll change.
Like, I'm all into color now.
I may go back to
black and white.
I don't know what
I'm going to do.
I just know that every
moment I go into a photograph
and process, there's
this creative muse
who says, "I'd like some
more texture, please."
And I give her more texture.
I don't argue with her anymore.
And like, I used to say, "Oh,
that's not going to work."
Because she'll go,
"Fine, whatever."
And then I don't hear
from her again for a year.
That's sucks.
So now, I listen to her.
So I really believe,
I feel, I experience,
and I see, that in our
photography and in our art,
there is the possibility-- maybe
the only possibility you have
in your life at this
time, I don't know,
I don't know your lives, but to
allow that spark of divine fire
to come through you,
inform your art,
and it will inform your life.
You'll have no choice.
So I see that my signature
is my point of view.
I see that my legacy is actually
my soul's voice enlivened
by the breath of the divine.
Oddly enough, I see it that way.
And that my art and my
photography is my gateway.
And I'm not going to tell
anybody what to make of it.
I'm just going to do it.
I'm just going to show
up with guns blazing
and do the best I can put
that across and let it go.
Because I'm not going to
tell you what to think.
But I'm going to do
my best to share it.
It was George Bernard Shaw who
said, "I have my own soul--
my own spark of divine fire."
And he said it in
"Pygmalion," the book
that became "My Fair Lady."
Henry Higgins was all
mad when he said this
because Eliza had
walked out on him.
he's like, "You can't
do that to be, me!
I have my own soul!
My own spark of divine fire!"
But it is so true, so applies
to what we're all doing here,
and to what you're all are doing
at Google, which is incredible.
And Google+ has changed
so many live-- mine!
The opportunities and the
things that I think about
because of Google+ and because
of the spark of divine fire
that you all have brought
has changed everything.
So I hope you keep doing it.
I hope you keep letting
all of us do it.
And that you just let it
come through and let it
be whatever it's
going to be next.
Because it will be amazing.
And so, the light prevails.
And thank you.
I hope you take
that into your life.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]